She composed for the legendary Aretha Franklin.
Beyoncé called her “one of the best rappers
ever.”
And OutKast even opened for her.
We’re talking about no one other than Ms.
Lauryn Hill.
Her talent is undeniable.
Rolling Stone named her one of the greatest
singers of all time, and Time Magazine dubbed
her the “Queen of Hip Hop.”
But she only released one studio album, so
how did she accomplish so much?
This is Ms. Lauryn Hill’s story and how
she became one of the most celebrated, influential,
and respected artists in music history.
First, let’s go way back to before she became
a music icon and a household name.
In 1987, L. Boogie performed at the famous
live show Amateur Night at the Apollo … and
was boo’d.
At the tender age of 13, the songbird performed
The Jackson 5’s “Who’s Loving You”
in front of a crowd, notoriously known for
being relentless critics.
But as she continued to sing, the crowd eventually
came around and clapped for the singer in
the end, not knowing that they had just witnessed
the beginning of history.
Three years later, Ms. Hill would make another
public appearance as a background dancer in
the music video for “Poor Georgie” by
MC Lyte.
But she wouldn’t stay in the background
for long.
Picture it.
The scene is Columbia High School in Maplewood,
New Jersey.
Prakazrel Michel, known as "Pras,” approaches
Ms. Hill about joining a group.
He would later introduce her to Wyclef Jean,
and together they became to be known as the
Fugees.
As they worked on their debut album Ms. Hill
continued her acting career…
Which led to her getting cast as Rita Louise
Watson in Sister Act 2 alongside Whoopi Goldberg.
The film served as a breakout film for Ms.
Hill, who also contributed to the soundtrack.
In 1994, the Fugees dropped their first album,
Blunted on Reality.
The New York Times said the album “concocts
brash, smart raps, drawing on Jamaican dance
hall rhythms as well as American hip-hop.”
And Ms. Hill was a standout.
She showed the ability to switch between being
a hard-hitting rapper like Ice Cube…
…to being effortlessly jazzy with her delivery.
But it wasn’t until their sophomore album,
The Score, was released that the Fugees reached
new levels of success.
In The Score, they found their own unique
voice.
Pras and Wyclef leaned more into their Caribbean
heritage (Fugees is short for Refugees, after
all) and Ms. Hill brought more of her bluesy
inspiration.
L. Boogie’s soulful talent is on full display
in their chilling hit single, “Ready or
Not.”
Ms. Hill lays her heart bare, with emotional
vocals and even cried while recording, before
delivering one of her most popular lines…
But it was Ms. Hill’s cover of “Killing
Me Softly with His Song,” that ended up
being the most popular single from the album.
In the middle of the hard-hitting 15-track
rap album, Ms. Hill brought new life to the
‘70s song.
With a sample from A Tribe Called Quest…
… the track’s hip-hop production matched
with Ms. Hill’s raspy-yet-smooth voice and
made this song an instant classic.
Just listen to this run…
The Score went on to win the Grammy Award
for Best Rap Album, making Ms. Hill the first
woman to win a Grammy in that category.
A love triangle and creative and financial
disagreements — made it hard for the Fugees
to continue forward as a group.
After Ms. Hill and Wyclef Jean ended their
tumultuous relationship, the Fugees broke
up, and Ms. Hill went solo.
An early-20-something year old Ms. Hill, started
crafting the early parts of an album in her
living room in her hometown South Orange,
New Jersey.
Her label reportedly wanted her to release
another album with the Fugees, but Ms. Hill
forged ahead by recruiting her own team to
help her achieve her vision.
She told Rolling Stone, “[I wanted to] write
songs that lyrically move me and have the
integrity of reggae and the knock of hip-hop
and the instrumentation of classic soul.”
Between label pressure to wrap up the album,
naysayers, filming the movie Restaurant, and
giving birth to her son, Zion, she got it
done.
For her debut solo album, The Miseducation
of Lauryn Hill, she drew from her personal
experience to create a raw, emotional cross-genre
album that explored themes of love, Black
empowerment, social justice, femininity, motherhood,
and more.
She lays out all of her emotions on the album.
In the soulful ballad “Ex-Factor” she
mourns her relationship with Wyclef Jean…
In “Ex-Factor,” although she’s singing,
her voice bounces on top of the beat in a
way that embodies a rap flow.
This sound would also help pave the way for
neo-soul music alongside the artistry of Erykah
Badu, Floetry, and Jill Scott.
You can hear Ms. Hill’s Motown soul influence
in songs like Doo Wop (That Thing)
The track’s hook and riff samples the soul
band the 5th Dimension.
In Doo Wop, Ms. Hill also showcases her lyrical
flare, proving why Miseducation is seen as
one of the best rap albums…
The album is also influenced by Jamaican dancehall
as well as the philosophy and sounds of reggae.
Half of the album was recorded at Bob Marley’s
Studio in Jamaica, and at the time she was
in a relationship with Marley’s son Rohan.
In the track “Lost Ones” Ms. Hill’s
vocals call back to Sister Nancy’s hit dancehall
record, “Bam Bam”
To learn more about the influence of the Miseducation,
I sat down with Nadirah, The founder of The
Gumbo, a magazine that celebrates Black women
in Hip Hop.
I think one thing that we don't talk about
a lot, though, at least I love to talk about,
is the blues.
…The influence of blues artists in her music.
And I think if you're hearing the call and
response and old blues songs and you're hearing
Lauryn sing and you're hearing them respond
with chants and stuff like that and shouting,
especially on songs like To Zion, it's just
so prevalent and it's so obvious there.
… And when it comes to women and blues and
how they were using, if you think about Ma
Rainey, you think about Bessie Smith, they
were using the blues to talk about, you know,
love and relationship issues and family and
heartbreak and all these different things
that weren't really being done in that way
in music.
And I think that's what makes it such a great
body of work, is that she is taking all of
these things and taking all these influences
and really making them her own and just nodding
to all these different parts of the music
that we have.
Now let’s talk stats.
The album, which is her only solo album to
date, would become one of the most highly-acclaimed
albums of all time.
With over 20 million copies sold worldwide,
it debuted at the No. 1 spot on the Billboard
200 chart, breaking Madonna’s record for
first-week sales by a female artist.
During that time, she was also a musical guest
on Saturday Night Live, and had a sold-out
worldwide tour
And let’s not forget about her ten Grammy
nominations and five wins including Album
of the year, making her the first rapper to
win Album of the Year.
Ms. Hill’s talent earned her the respect
from her predecessors and peers.
In an interview with Billboard, Grammy-nominated
rapper Rapsody said,
“She knew how to incorporate melody into
a rhyme so people could sing along with her,
even as she was rapping about things that
might have been complex.”
In the same interview, Lizzo noted that “She
set the bar.
I was always afraid of being a singer, but
then when I heard Lauryn Hill, I was like,
“Maybe I can do both.”
Even though the Miseducation of Lauryn Hill
was such a great success, the world is still
waiting for a sophomore album over 20 years
later.
Ms. Hill said that lack of support and ideological
differences were the reasons it never happened.
In an interview with Rolling Stone, Ms. Hill
said
“No one from my label has ever called me
and asked ‘how can we help you make another
album…ever [...] With the Miseducation,
there was no precedent.
I was, for the most part, free to explore,
experiment and express.
After the Miseducation, there were scores
of tentacled obstructionists, politics, repressing
agendas, unrealistic expectations, and saboteurs
everywhere.”
With only one solo album, some think that
Ms. Hill’s legacy stops with Miseducation,
but that’s not true.
In 2002, she released an MTV Unplugged album,
which includes a performance of “Mystery
of Iniquity” that was later sampled in Kanye
West’s “All Falls Down.”
Ms. Hill also wrote and produced songs for
legends like Aretha Franklin, Mary J. Blige,
CeCe Winans, Whitney Houston, and Santana.
Why do you think Miss Lauryn Hill has only
released one album?
Everyone talks about this so much.
And also, I couldn't imagine creating something
like The Miseducation of Lauryn Hill, Lauryn
Hill, and then trying to follow it up with
all that pressure on me because, one, I gave
y'all something really good.
I also did the live album.
I haven't completely like disappeared or whatever,
but I'm also a human being.
Ms. Hill continues to tour and performs new
renditions of her songs to keep it fresh for
her audiences — and herself.
Since the Fugees broke up in 1997, they’ve
performed together a few times, and there’s
been talk of another reunion.
And while she draws criticism for only releasing
one studio album…
her influence can be heard in the music of
today’s chart toppers like Beyoncé, Adele,
J. Cole, Drake, and Cardi B…
I feel like a lot of the young artists, especially
because I'm an R&B, especially R&B.
Yeah, take a lot of Lauryn influence.
They definitely do.
And even I feel like a lot of the women who
rap now, too, if you ask them, you know, who
are your favorite almost all the time, they
say Lauryn Hill.
And I'm just like, this is a testament to
her impact.
Good night you guys, thank you very much.
Before you go, I want to let you know about
Fight The Power: How Hip-Hop Changed the World.
A new PBS series hosted by Hip-Hop legend
Chuck D. It’s about how Hip-Hop became a
global movement that spoke truth to power.
Check out the link in the description below
and let them know Sound Field sent you.